propositional operators play a basic
role in the design of digital circuitry
and we're going to illustrate that in
this section by designing a little
binary addition circuit so let's begin
with a review of binary notation and
addition and binary so the way binary
works is like decimal except instead of
using powers of 10 you're using powers
of 2 so here is the binary
representation of the number 39 the way
to understand that is this is the ones
place that's the twos place that's the
forest place so at 1 plus 2 plus 4 is 7
then this is the 8th place with nothing
this is the 16th place with something
and this is the 32 place with 1 so we
add 32 to 7 and get 39 likewise the
binary representation of 28 is 0 1 1 1 0
0 I'll let you check out that works with
contributing 1 2 4 8 16 and 32 and
finally let's add these two numbers in
binary
now binary addition works just like
decimal addition except that the only
numbers are ones and zeros so that when
you get 1 plus 1 you have to carry one
let's do that so 1 plus 0 is 1 that
fills in the first column then we have
another 1 plus 0 is 1 that's fine now we
have a 1 plus 1 and that's gonna do a 0
here and contribute a carry of 1 to the
next column
now the next column has two ones so it
becomes a 0 and contributes to another
carry now we have two ones we get a 0
and contribute another carry and now we
have two ones and we finally get a 1 0
so this is the binary representation of
the sum and you can check that this is 1
plus 2 is 3 plus 64 so the answer should
be 67 and you can check that it is so
that's how binary addition works now
let's try to design a bit of circuitry
using digital logic the signals of 0 & 1
which will do addition and so we're
going to try to design a
little 6 bit binary addition circuits so
I'm going to have as inputs the six
digits of the first binary number a 5
down through a zero and then the second
binary number let's call it B zero
through B 5 so these are two binary
numbers six digits long and I'm going to
add them up by thinking of a 1 is 0 or 1
signal a 0 is a 0 1 signal B 0 is a 0 1
signal these can be transmitted down
wires into some boxes that contain
digital operators that will cause the
right signals to come out and what we
want to come out of here is the possibly
seven digit representation of their
binary sum so these 0 is the sum of a 0
and B 0 the lower did you possibly with
a carry and so on and then C 5 is if the
number if the sum of two six digit
numbers runs to seven digits which it
might as we saw in the previous example
and C five would become one of the Y's
zero so this is the specification I want
a and B to come in and I want their
binary sum to come out as these with a
high order seed if need be now the way
you're going to do that is it's clear
that the behavior of the inputs for a
and B which produced a lower digit might
produce a carry and that carry has to be
transmitted to the next column
if it exists and so I'm going to need a
wire that sends a 0 1 signal from this
box over to that one that can be
carrying this that carries 0 or 1 and
likewise for all of the others so this
is the kind of basic structure of my
binary additions circuit this is called
a ripple carry organization its limiting
its mimicking exactly the way that we
added up the two numbers column by
column possibly propagating a comma
column on carry of 0 1 or really a carry
of just 1 to the next column and I've
got all the wires in place that I need
what we need to do is design the digital
circuitry that's in those boxes well
this box is different from the others
because it's only got 2 in
puts all the others have three inputs so
the three input boxes we'll call full
adders and the two input boxes a half an
adder and the specification of a half an
adder again is that the output is the
binary representation of a 0 plus a 0
plus B 0 so it's a 2 binary
representation never be bigger than 2
because there's only two numbers the
output of a full adder is it gets inputs
of 3 inputs in this case B 1 a 1 and the
carry C 0 and it produces the binary
representation of the sum of those three
numbers which is a two digit binary
representation there might be anything
from 0 to 3 ok well let's start with the
easy case what's a half adder well a
half adder again has inputs being a and
it's supposed to produce as output the
binary representation of B plus a so B
is the lower digit in the the 0 or the
the zeros place and C is the high or
digit namely the twos place well what
does that look like well here's the
circuit this is the digital designers
symbol for a exclusive or gate that
returns so D is going to be the
exclusive or of a and B according to
this pictorial diagnose I am notice I'm
using this colon colon equal symbol
which is convenient as a reminder that
this is that I'm defining the thing on
the left so this is you can replace it
by equal but it's informative to realize
that it's not an equality that you've
proved or if in some derivation the two
interesting things are proven to be
equal but rather than I'm just defining
what D is so D is Devon this output D is
defined to be a XOR B and likewise this
is a NAND gate so the outputs a is a and
B and let's check that the lower two
digit is definitely the month to sum the
XOR of a and B and when is there a carry
well the only way does a carry went is
when the value is 2 in which case the
output C would be 1 and D would be 0 and
that's exactly when both a and B or 1
that is C is a and B so that's a half
adder that was easy
well a full adder looks like this it's a
little bit more complicated
and I'm gonna write out the equations
without trying to justify them
completely but I need a name in order to
describe this with with propositional
operators I need a name for that
important signal call it s which is what
we we're not calling in the previous one
but now this is a half adder with inputs
a and B and outputs s which is a XOR B
and another output here in which we know
is just going to be a and B ok how do i
express this set of connections as
formulas well first of all s is the
output of this first half adder which is
a XOR B okay the output D I get by
taking s and it's the first output of
the second half adder which means it's
CN XOR s that's easy and what about C
out well C out is getting and this is an
or gate by the way so C out is going to
be an or of what comes out of this half
adder which is C in and C s and or with
the output of this half adder which is
just a and B so there are a bunch of
equations that completely characterize
the structure of this little bit of
digital logic and how it is wired up and
fits together now let's go back to
describing our ripple-carry circuit of
what was going on here now that we have
the equations that characterize the
behavior of these full adders and half
adders I can explain to you what the
formulas are for all of these outputs
the C's and the DS and that goes as
follows so the first one looking at this
half adder with a0 b0 coming in and C 0
D 0 coming out I know that D 0 is a 0 X
or B 0 and C 0 is a 0 and B 0 that's
just the formulas that we have for the
half adder when the inputs are a 0 and B
0 and I call the outputs the 0 and C 0
now the more general case of the full
adder what's coming in here is an A and
a B with the same subscript AI and bi
and
coming out is the eighth digit of the
binary some di and the carry CI and I
can describe those just by using the
formulas for the full adder so what it
means is that I'm going to introduce a
new convenient variable si which I'm
going to define to be AI or X or bi di
is then going to be CI minus 1 that
carry from the previous place ex-ored
with Si and the new carry CI is going to
be the out of the output of the second
half adder of the first half adder which
is CI minus 1 and si or the output of
the first half adder which is AI and bi
so the point is that I've just taken the
the wiring and translated into equations
like this and you can see how these
equations might be more fair to use then
the particular way that you drew the
picture with all the wires connected
because the logical behavior of the
circuit doesn't depend on how it's laid
out it just depends on these logical
connectives between the values of these
different variables